you
good morning everyone
i'd like to
call the fiscal committee meeting
to order
okay on the agenda our first thing is
acceptance of minutes
could i have a motion please
thank you senator d'alessandro
second
by senator representative edwards
are there any
yes
8-1
okay is there anyone that
is interested in taking fis
seeing none we will proceed now to the
if i'm not mistaken
if
oh i'm sorry yeah
take off the table i'm sorry thank you
at this time i have the following
items to be taken off the table
the first one under tab 4
fis2223
under tab five
fis-22208
fis-22224
fis2236
yes tab seven excuse me
yeah
fis
fis22238
are there any other items to come off
yes senator thank you i think i
had been the person who wanted to take
208 off the table
but um based on the department's
responses to the questions i don't feel
the need to do that anymore so
i'm happy to leave it on consent okay is
there anyone that objects to leaving
sisfis
saying none it will
be on the consent calendar thank you
could i have a motion please to accept
all of the other items on the consent
calendar
oh
they're not they're not on the consent
calendar
okay
could i have a motion to approve all of
the i other items on the consent
calendar senator rosenwald second
yeah i think we better
okay
consent calendar representative edwards
yes
represents representative earth yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator morse
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair the vote is uh nine to zero
thank you very much nine to zero
um
under tab four
and that is the um
good morning for the record frank
edelblut commissioner of education
tammy vallancourt cfo for education
welcome on this beautiful friday morning
uh i do want to say
excuse me just a second but before
everybody walks out the door
i would like to say that um
the explanations that were sent in this
time
were much better than what they have
been in the past
and i i really want to thank
uh the commissioners and the folks that
are actually preparing those
explanations
for the
work that they have been doing over the
last
six months to
to improve the explanations
so tab four
fis2223
uh is there someone that has a question
on this
senator d'alessandro
thank you very much madam chair uh
nice to see you commissioner
commissioner uh i i love this one uh 580
thousand dollars for better use
what is better use
uh
that's that's a rather expensive term
better use i think that's a fair
criticism but i could use a half a
million for for better use yeah moving
it my way
so basically what we're doing here
relative to this account is um having
looked at where we were relative to the
spending on this program um and seeing
the upcoming ending of the grant
we are moving some of those funds around
um
you know you'll see much of that
funding is is
passed through funding in terms of
federal grants and that's to the schools
so we're going to pass an additional 420
000 back through to the schools
um and then we're also going to be and
and we were not able to hire some
positions so we saved some money in
terms of attempt full time and we're
going to move that into both those funds
that transfer to the schools as well as
some contracts with
choose love and mostly unh for their
youth mental health first aid program
so
fair enough criticism that it's not
necessarily a better use but it is we're
trying to maximize the use of those
funds by putting them at programs that
we think are effective
thank you
if i could continue yes
wouldn't it wouldn't it have been more
appropriate for you to say i have got
half a million dollars
and these are the better uses i find for
that money categorically list those so
that we know where that money
money is going i mean we're we're budget
people we follow the budget
and we ought to know where the money is
being spent i think it's a fair
criticism and i agree thank you thank
you ben
you're welcome are there any further
questions
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair
is is this money related to the
one million dollars that dhhs
uh asked us to move last time where
where the purpose of that million
dollars was to establish um clinical and
mental health care in some schools so
that would not be that is part of bdas
so the state commission on substance
misuse this is part of our system of
care grant from the federal government
through samsa
follow-ups
follow-up
okay so i i i think i support this um i
i just want to make sure that if there's
a coordination issue between dhhs and
their million-dollar spend and and your
spend that that coordination happens
and i don't even know if it's
appropriate it's just that we're moving
big chunks of money in the last two
fiscal committees
towards school-based programs so i just
want to make sure we're in sync okay
thank you
seeing none will the clerk
oops i need a motion uh move the end
thank you senator d'alessandro do i have
a second
sent
[Music]
will the clerk please call the roll
two 22-223 representative edwards yes on
two two three
enrique voces
representative earth yes
representative elishman yes
senator daniels yes senator morse yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator alessandro yes representative
humberger yes
and i'm sure the vote is ten to zero
thank you vote being ten to zero
fis
we now turn to fis
under
nope still four
uh under tab
four
fis2224
fis22224
department of
good morning uh good morning members of
the
committee i'm bob for the record i'm bob
scott uh commissioner with the
department of environmental services and
uh with me is our chief operating
officer susan carlson and i'm pleased to
answer any questions uh regarding this
item
questions from the committee
uh senator daniels thank you thank you
commissioner um
can you define what a natural disaster
is
i mean if i
if i have a well and suddenly i get a
break in my pipe
because
the ground kind of gives way or whatever
i don't know if that's a natural
disaster it might be to me if i don't
have water right
so thank you for the question senator so
uh i'm i have hard copies but i also
sent you all by email uh kind of
the
we call it one pagers for the drinking
water groundwater trust fund this
information will also be on the website
soon as you approve so so the homeowners
know that that information too but the
intent of this is not to
uh pay for for low-income uh qualifying
uh
well owners uh things like that the
maintenance or gi had a lightning strike
and my motor needs to be replaced it's
intended to be for
um
irreversible water supply issues caused
by a natural disaster now that's where
it could be a earthquake it could be a
hurricane
that salinates water that wasn't before
it but it
so i guess i'm not
we haven't defined what a natural
disaster is but it has to be something
that was not man-made not contamination
from a release of something but
something uh
that was caused by nature if you will
but it also has to be uh irreversible in
in scope so i'll give you a couple
examples again so
uh
let's say there's an earthquake that
drains the aquifer that your your well
is in so now you can't there is no water
for you to get that would qualify as an
example or again as i just mentioned
say your well is on the seacoast a major
hurricane comes through and now all the
water in that aquifer is
the salt content is too much to be
potable that would qualify
by way of background this is really an
off uh builds off of the
drought program that the drinking water
groundwater trust fund has been
operating for a while now uh in similar
we have similar contacts this is an
expansion of that because we realized
drought is a good example
but that's not the only example we want
to be prepared to be able to provide
assistance to our citizens
thank you
senator d'alessandro thank you madam
chair
uh for just just two things
what's the income level you've
established to uh
to identify low income new hampshire
homeowners
uh served by residential wells that's
number one
and and how how do you ascertain whether
it's irreversible or not
right so thank you for that uh senator
so the last question first i think uh we
did we did give ourselves some some
leeway so to be fair what we said is up
to the department's discretion to
determine that but those are the the
type of examples i was giving uh so we
we tip we in the trust fund discuss this
as they were approving this the uh the
commission uh we don't want it to be
something like gee my my my motor needs
to be replaced those are maintenance
issues not not irreversible the water
supply is not available to you anymore
issues uh as far as the uh income levels
and again i'm happy to hand out two if
you want but we do have thresholds that
are built in that are very much based on
what we
are currently still doing for the
drought program so it's based on uh hud
income guidance and then uh mhi and
within that we built tiers
uh for how much assistance uh will be
available to to folks if that helps
thank you and again
obviously for your constituents too this
will all be posted on our website
as a tool so
hopefully we don't have any natural
disasters but in the off chance we do uh
you you can also if somebody ask you not
obviously feel free to call me i hope
you know that but you can also look
point them to the website and say here's
a potential assistance that can you can
get thank you thank you thank you madam
chair
uh representative edwards uh thank you
madam chairman my my questions are sort
of similar but um let me let me let me
say it this way instead of in a form of
a question i i
whenever i see these kinds of programs
where we're
taking uh
public monies and sending it directly to
reimburse an individual
i get concerned about
the transparency and the openness of the
process
because
some people are just better informed
than others and and so i i heard you say
you're going to be putting the
availability of this on your website
but do you think that's really
sufficient to make sure that
people who are just generally unaware of
public policy that that somehow we're
reaching out and letting them know that
there's a resource here for them as well
i i agree with you it's probably not
sufficient in a vacuum
all by itself but again i'll point to
our drought program so we have staff
that work that program
uh we try to target areas when
unfortunately when we are in severe
drought and that's
you know we just kind of got get out of
one it looks like we may be possibly
getting back into one for some areas of
the state so the state the the staff try
to do uh more targeted outreach also uh
so that the the the bene the good part
of
of this is
uh it's not really a hundred percent on
the homeowner because we're working with
the well drillers
uh so the people providing that actual
work for them and they're aware of it
also so so we have a little bit of a
multiplier in getting out the word so
when somebody
it doesn't solve everything but when
somebody uh the drug program is getting
as my example is contacting the well
driller saying i i don't have enough
water what can i do with that type of
thing that the the driller
in this case knows in the equipment
suppliers are the same
to be able to offer that that program up
because that actually to be blunt for
them it helps get them a sale but also
helps provide that information to the
the well owner that this is available to
them even if they didn't know it
otherwise so so we are looking for other
outreach uh and again um
that's half the reason why i bring it up
to you that will be on our website
because i want you as legislators to be
aware of it
also uh did you have a follow-up i i do
and and thank you because you
anticipated my follow-up about
contacting the drillers themselves uh
and so that sounds like a good approach
to me uh are you
confident that you're hitting a hundred
by and large yes i i i never want to say
we're a hundred percent for anything but
uh
our understanding and working with them
because the well drillers you know we
regulate that so they
whether they want to listen to us or not
they they at least have to say they are
uh so so they have at least been made
available that information to them yes
senator morris
senator morris uh
moves the item in representative edward
seconds
will the clerk please call the rule
on 224
representative edwards yes hamrick vote
chess representative irf yes
representative leisman yes senator
daniels yes senator morris yes senator
gray yes senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes representative umberger
yes madam chair the vote is ten to zero
thank you vote being ten to zero the
item passes
fi or tab 7
fis2236
good morning again frank edelblut
commissioner of education good morning
jen harper i'm the director for homeland
are there questions
representative edwards uh thank you
madam chair um
i i think i know the answer but i'm
compelled to ask because my school asked
me to ask um we did a school bond at the
auburn village school
three years ago
and we put about seven hundred thousand
dollars into physical security upgrades
in accordance with the homeland defense
audit that we
asked for
and so my school would like to
participate in getting some of this
money to help with the 700 000 that we
spent a couple years ago is there any
provision for that or is that impossible
so in the public school infrastructure
fund grants that were initially provided
in 2018 those did include the ability to
do retroactive reimbursement for
amounts that had been already spent
towards qualified security projects
i'm looking at the thing so auburn had
received 122 000 towards that at that
period of time
um in the current grant we do not
anticipate that there will be a
retroactive provision for school
projects that have already been done
the objective in this next range of
money is to continue to
make our environment more secure so
while we appreciate that the communities
have already made those security
measures and brought those forward
in this grand tranche we're going to
continue to provide enhance and
improvements to that security further
so i think you kind of just said what i
told them up front which is we probably
can't ask for retroactive money but
with this funding if there are some
additional security items on their on
their list they can apply for it still
absolutely in fact that's what we're
hoping to see so we've got our security
plans in our schools those have been
evaluated through homeland security
we've identified
security risks in this grant process
which has not been you know finally
approved by the commission but the
homeland security and department of
education have been working on we
anticipate being able to rank those
security risks and we will fund the
highest risk items first thank you very
much
are there any further ques uh senator
d'alessandro thank you madam chair thank
you and thank you commission
commission the the money's available for
both public and non-public schools uh
tell me the realm that constitutes the
non-public venues
so what we're basically doing is we're
using the public school infrastructure
fund processes for this but we have so
far secured two and seeking a third
funding source that don't come with
those same limitations and so you've got
3.3 million dollars that is in the
public school infrastructure fund
and this is a as a result of funding
that was um not used out of the first
tranche projects that came in under
budget um and so that fund those 3.3
would be limited by statute to
only public schools the two other
funding sources that we're seeking are
arp arpa funds
which don't come with that same
restriction as well as eans funds so
emergency assistance in non-public
schools
which was the federal grant that was
designated for non-public schools and so
to the extent that we receive those
we're going to put that those funds into
the tranche and then we expect that we
will fund the highest risk projects
relative to students in new hampshire
for the question yes please go ahead and
a
uh
has a list been
compiled of all of the schools received
money initially and what they did with
that money it'd be who decides what the
height what's the criteria being used to
to to designate risk
so we do have a list and we can provide
that to you if you'd like to see that i
know for example manchester received uh
1.517 million in the first ranch yes um
and so
so we can provide that to you that's no
problem in terms of what is going to be
funded in this next round is uh homeland
security and i don't know if you want to
speak to this gem but we'll go through
kind of a ranking process so we're going
to open up a grant window if you
remember in the last grant process we
did a rolling grant just to get that
money out and deploy as quickly as
possible in this tranche we anticipate
doing a grant window will allow the
grant applications to be received those
will be scored by homeland security in
terms of how risky they are and then we
will deploy that money according to the
grant source of the three different
sources and what's allowable under those
various sources
thank you
are there further questions
seeing none could i have a motion to
accept
thank you senator daniels to have a
second
senator gray thank you
will the clerk please call the role
roll call on two three six
representative edwards yes
votes yes represent yes representative
leishman yes senator daniels yes senator
morse
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes madam chair
the vote is 10-0
thank you the vote being 10-0
fis-22236
passes
we now turn to still in tab 7
from the governor's office for emergency
good morning everyone taylor casual
commissioner gopher
uh is there a question yes uh
representative leitchman thank you madam
chair thank you for
being here today so who sets the
60 40 rate as far as the
requirement to provide the match
that is a
a provision of this program that we
instituted in order to be able to
maximize the use of the
funds rather question if i could
sure follow up
so as you know we've heard from
communities like in getting emergency
funds they have to provide like 20 and
some have said that's not sufficient or
they don't have the 20
so in this particular case are you
confident that nursing homes can come up
with the
required match or should it be higher
like again who is it the federal
government setting this 60 40 or is it
the state it's the state in this
particular program and we've done this
in a number of other programs in fact
the invest nh program has a match
requirement that's actually a 100
requirement
this uh i think reflects the fact that
for the most part what we're seeking to
do with these funds are larger size
projects that require um a good amount
of work to be able to complete
whether capital investments
infrastructure investments pro you know
building renovations and those sorts of
things
that given the arp of restrictions in
terms of timing really becomes a
question as to how far along
are the projects that we're going to be
able to fund at this point and be able
to see them complete prior to the
the termination of the arpa deadlines
so all of those pieces go together um
when we're looking for ways to make
investments that we can stretch the
dollars as far as we possibly can for
this particular instance and also be
able to recognize that
these are typically four projects that
have some level of maturity um and
effectively in a pipeline
already for the most part
thank you thank you madam chair
senator rosenwald thank you madam chair
of a couple of questions
um
the there's been no
real specific
post coveted pandemic analysis
in long-term care facilities
done
by the department of health and human
services
um there have been a couple of two years
in a row some legislative attempts
to appropriate money to do that to hire
an outside consultant but that has not
and since
the department was not involved
in developing this program
what are you
basing the determination that this will
these projects will
mitigate the next pandemic
well i think a couple of things uh first
off i mean as we all know the long-term
care and nursing home
sector saw pretty significant impacts
um as we went through the pandemic and a
lot of those were
outbreaks and spreaders that were
occurring within those spaces with staff
and with
residents and family members
we know
we're we're it's fairly well documented
that renovations that will allow for
additional spacing and safety measures
to be put into place as a general rule
whether it's covert or not flu other
types of
viruses that spread through nursing
homes
this
funding provides us an opportunity
to make those investments for
covid type pandemics or future pandemics
and and really mitigate the risk that
comes to those very vulnerable residents
so
whether it's the spacing with
renovations or whether it's making
investments that will significantly
enhance air circulation in a building
through hvac
these are all things that uh county
nursing homes have difficulty making
investments from a capital standpoint
and we're we're hoping that this program
is going to be able to
advance those that are in that pipeline
significantly and really reduce the risk
going forward
follow-up thank you
without the participation of the
department and the subject matter
experts
how how is
gopher going to be able to determine
what the
best
ranking of these projects will be to
have
the most
mitigating impact
well i i don't think it's fair to say
that we've not ever spoken with hhs
about this program but i think the the
fact is that this is a this is a
development program an infrastructure
investment program
into nursing homes that we know
are in need of these types of
investments and these this is an
opportunity again to take funding that's
available for this one moment in time
make those investments that are going to
last way beyond
uh any of us
and so uh i you know i
i feel fairly confident that the ability
to manage
what 10 or 11 nursing homes in counties
and their infrastructure requirements is
within the capability of gopher but also
in you know we don't do these things in
a vacuum if there are instances where we
have to have input from other
departments we do that every single day
follow-up thank you
um
have you had conversations more follow
up on representative leishman's question
have you had conversations with
all 10 counties and what kinds of
assurances
have you gotten that they they are
willing to front
the 60 of the money
or will a lot of this 50 million be
i think i would say that this program is
designed to provide a tool to county
nursing homes that are in a position to
be able to use it um we know at least of
a couple that have um have expressed an
interest in the county nursing home
representatives have expressed support
for this program this is 50 million
dollars of investments
that we hope will be able to again make
those types of investments in the long
term for these nursing homes and their
vulnerable populations
one more if i could yes thank you
so the worst
devastation in long-term care
occurred at the veterans home where 20
of their residents died from coven in
two months why why
are you not including them
are they not interested does federal law
prohibit
us from
helping them with capital projects why
not go where the devastation was the
absolute worst well i mean i
absolutely acknowledge that i think this
program in the scheme of you know dozens
and dozens of programs that we've pushed
through is for specifically county
nursing homes in this instance
there may be a demonstrated interest in
moving a project forward for other
specific types of institutions such as
the one you refer to but this is a
county nursing home program
thank you
representative leishman
uh thanks manager i'd like to just drill
down a little bit more on one of
senator rosenwald's question
have you specifically got a list working
with the department of health and human
services who works daily with
county nursing homes about their needs
or is this 50 million dollars kind of
like what you're putting out there and
then those with need will come forward
do you have like any specifics
we are basing the program in a
recognition that nursing homes uh
and the role that they play and that the
experience that they have been through
can be mitigated with investments in
their infrastructure whether it's hvac
new heating systems in some cases they
may want to be looking at efficiency
upgrades given what we're seeing in the
energy markets right now
but there are also
counties such as sullivan county that is
very far along and a very substantial
rehabilitation of their entire facility
and this program would uh provide some
assistance in helping them achieve that
there may be other nursing homes that
have projects that are of similar size
or probably
much smaller in size
but from the standpoint of
making an investment to reduce the
potential transmission of covid or in
fact other
viruses within the nursing home this is
an opportunity to make those investments
thanks madam chair are there any
how will funding energy efficiency
upgrades
reduce the spread of a virus as part of
an hvac upgrade um senator that you
typically you will want to make
investments if you're making a
significant investment in a in a new in
a new capital project that will
improve the air circulation and the
heating efficiency and cooling of a
building you're also going to make
investments in
the efficiency of the envelope of that
building in order to maximize the
benefit
could we ask that
we
data that supports
energy efficiency projects mitigating
against viral transmission
if i could just continue on that point i
think that it's
we're talking about making an investment
in the hvac
components of a building that in in
from the standpoint of
viral transmission will increase the
capability to reduce those
viral transmissions by circulating the
air
as a result of making those investments
for the air circulatory benefits you are
also going to achieve energy efficiency
benefits as a result of installing a
more efficient hvac system that's the
i guess we want to be reassured that
circulating the air around is not just
going to blow virus throughout
the facility that's why
i'm hoping you can provide us with that
backup data
which data specifically that shows that
these energy efficiency
air circulation projects will reduce
virus
by its design a new hvac system that
will be used to
impart to circulate air is going to
increase the efficiency of the building
senator d'alessandro
thank you madam chant
uh
commissioner i i don't know a lot about
heating and air conditioning but my dad
was in the business all of his life
my brother was in the business all of
his life hvac
if you could promote air exchange and
that's the removal of the bad air and
bringing in a better ear that might
solve the problem but recirculating
than exist
at the moment because if you're
recirculating existing here what you're
doing is you're taking what's in that
air and just redistributing it over and
over again within the facility i agree
completely
so hvac uh
look at if you want to air condition the
situation that's that's one thing
uh that that's not going to save you any
money that's going to cost you money
that's a very expensive situation
i think the questions that uh are being
asked
are really
design
areas
when the
nursing home
uh figures out what they need to do
i'm not
you know i
i would hope
that
whomever the um
[Music]
the nursing homes choose to do whatever
work needs to be done
that they would ensure
that it meets the um safety standards
hvac but also for
space in rooms
and so i i
i understand where you're coming from
the gopher office
can
come to grips with
how the
various nursing homes
might design their nursing home
and i assume that the counties
would work closely
with
dhhs because i know their
rules out there and all kinds of
things that they have to follow
so
this is
in my opinion
is simply the money
to
allow the county nursing homes to move
forward
with required repairs
so that's
that's my two cents
senator
gray thank you
having worked at the portsmouth shipyard
and worked on air handling systems for
submarines that submerged for three
months at a time
the new air handling systems and correct
me if i'm wrong allow you the
opportunity to do other things
humidification is one of the things that
we've done for years
electrostatic precipitators and other
you know items that would help to clean
the air
and
mitigate the
rebreathing
you know of the air so so
i mean
there
along with the air handling stuff that
you're doing the new system that you're
putting in it gives you the opportunity
to make those modifications to do those
other things
that allow
are there any further questions
okay senator gray second
you please call the roll
we'll call on two three seven
representative edwards yes hamrick coach
yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator morse
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes madam chair
the vote is 10-0
the vote vote being 10-0
fis
22 237 passes
thank you very much
department of
good morning madam chair members of the
committee dennis goulet the commissioner
of the department of information
technology
are there questions
on fis 22 238
uh representative edwards
thank thank you madam chairman i i think
this feels like three different
questions but the first one up
is
um 459 thousand dollars for a one-year
license
for
just an interface
sounds like it's a tremendous amount of
money are are we
getting some application licensing as
well or are we just really licensing
the interface component
this this is actually licensing
for the platform and the application
that that would serve as as many
citizens as as wanted to be served in
the state of new hampshire so it's
pretty significant
in other words it's it's it runs it's
basically for all of vinnie
all right follow
okay so when i read this maybe i'm just
suffering poor reading it just sounded
like all this was it was a licensing for
the interface and not for the underlying
application if it's for that as well
then it sounds much better but okay um
so
this is 459 000 for one year license
will this same amount
show up in the next budget cycle uh two
two times 459 is is that where we're
going with this yes sir um it's a timing
issue now where we didn't you know
during the planning of this biennial
budget um we hadn't considered
that we were running pretty quickly on
on public health response stuff and then
actually didn't planned into this budget
but the intent is on the dhhs side to
yes please is is this is this the
application
that you all did a uh privacy impact
assessment on i know that you got
engaged a contractor to do one pia
and and i i'm and i'm seeing a head
shake of a no
so um so i'm just curious uh
although this really great bill died
this year i i'm hoping that the
department still keeps moving in the
direction of doing pias on sensitive
uh
sensitive applications and this vaccine
registry has gotten a lot of people's
attention so
if if you were to do a pia on this would
you need supplemental money beyond the
um so um thanks for the question um just
a comment
you can you can bring yeah david come on
up
don't don't struggle we're not
thank you
thank you david weeders information
services director for dhhs
so
in terms of doing privacy impact
assessments as we discussed in some of
the legislative bills that we were
working on we do not have sufficient
resources to do the robust privacy
impact assessments that would be
required for all of our systems however
we do have a robust security
process to look at all of our systems
this particular system
was developed by deloitte
on our sales force organization with our
team so it's really on our environment
and we've gone through all the security
practices to ensure that it's hipaa
compliant and follows all the
parameters that you would anticipate
from a pia or privacy impact assessment
were followed and we can certainly do
an overview pia on this this component
of the vaccine registration scheduling
and administration which is what this
okay just because it's my opportunity to
say one of my favorite quotes
that you you you you can you can have
um
secure and i can't even get the quotes
right now but anyways as you know
there's a distinction between security
and privacy
and and you you mentioned security
primarily in your remarks so is do you
think it's also uh covering the privacy
aspects your security look
thank you for the question certainly our
privacy officer was involved through the
development of the application and
reviewing reviewing it from a privacy
perspective as well as a security
perspective
and
just for this group's edification we are
looking at privacy by design in the
future so it will be privacy first
security second but you need both in
order to have a good system you need to
understand what you're securing why
you're securing it from a privacy
perspective and then you use security to
do it if that makes sense
follow-up so so i love that i love that
answer i i really do i i think um this
one's from mr glay
i i have mentioned a few times in fiscal
committee meetings and maybe an hhs
oversight that
we we're spending
a tremendous amount of money on a lot of
different i.t projects
and i keep coming back to the idea that
i'd really like to see a holistic
summary
of all of the it project work that we're
doing
because as we just fund each one of
these i'm just concerned whether or not
we're we're seeing the big picture the
aggregate of it and i i
this isn't the day to do that but i just
would like to encourage you to if you
have something like that already i'd i'd
be happy to come by your office and get
familiar with it
yes um in fact we are doing that right
now and we do it each each
in advance of the biennial plan a budget
planning process we do what's um called
an agency information technology plan
for each agency we work with the
agencies on the business side to do that
and that really talks about
from a business perspective what sort of
i t projects we're going to be doing or
planning during the
future biennium and our expectation is
that those plans align with budget
requests that that would be coming
through and we also take all of those
plans and we look at them and and use
them to guide our overall statewide
information technology strategy as well
so and i can share all of that with
senator daniels
thank you
commissioner in response to one of
representative edward's questions you
mentioned that uh
uh going forward you would be looking to
put this into the budget
yes sir
and so i i refer to the last statement
on on your uh information to us in the
event the federal funds are no longer
available general funds will not be
so i'm
wondering what it is if if we look at
the that was a tough question to answer
because and i think
that's partly incorrect answer i'd have
to say um but
when we look at the funding mix in other
words our
if it's flowing through class 27 um
which is our the doit budget then the
funding mix for dhhs is is largely not
general funds
uh if it we're flowing through a dhhs
budget line and we haven't discussed
that specifically then again
a lot of that it would would likely not
be general funds as well so but it isn't
so
to be to be clear then your intent is
for this
vaccine database to just go on
continuously
uh public health would like to have the
um the
registration and scheduling capability
ready should we need it
in the future
when looking around the country i was i
i was in place as the uh president of uh
the national association of state cios
during the pandemic and there
the the gold standard for states was to
have in terms of citizen service and
citizen response was to have a central
capability that that not only could
handle
the
central registration from an efficiency
and a service perspective but also could
scale to the entire population and this
system does that for new hampshire thank
you
senator rosenwald
thank you madam chair
given that there's a patient
portion portal
um at least either in place or imagined
are there any plans to
have vinnie interface with
the commercial pharmacy market
in new hampshire or other states
so that
if somebody's living
in southern new hampshire
they can schedule an appointment at a
so my understanding is this would not be
used for commercial pharmacy scheduling
most of the commercial pharmacy
organizations have their own scheduling
emr system to do that and
this is really focused on scheduling
registration and
administration of
vaccines or associated with covid flu
and other vaccines that public health
thank you madam chair
so in the absence of a pandemic and i
believe the last one was quite some time
ago
what benefit does this half million
dollars a year provide to the citizens
so that's a good question so
we're using salesforce for many
different components and having the
licensing allows us to leverage that
environment to build other applications
so in public health for example we're
using
salesforce for granite trace which is
our contact tracing patient monitoring
and case investigation system and we're
targeting other systems like our disease
surveillance system to be on the
salesforce platform so this specific
fund pays for the licensing for the
individuals in the immunization
group but it can be expanded and you
leverage across a larger enterprise
license agreement that we're negotiating
with salesforce to
reduce our costs over time
leveraging that one platform
follow follow-up
so is it fair to say that this money is
really not dedicated to
the covid pandemic but rather to
building out a sales force system for
whom are there other uses you might
decide to
use it for
i would i would say we need this funds
to be able to maintain the covet 19
solution if we didn't have the funds for
this we would have to turn that system
off
and then find else other funds in
excess of 459 000
to support all the other initiatives so
this is a component of what we can build
off of and so the idea is to not
duplicate effort and leverage this these
funds that are for covenant team to not
not just be wasted in the future but
also
be able to be leveraged for other
solutions as we go forward but it is
really right now for the kova 19
pandemic work
so i get that
but i also understand pandemics are
few and far between
whereas software changes dramatically
in years
much less decades or over the time over
turn of a century so the notion that
you're spending money on a lot of money
on salesforce licenses which will either
not be used
according to what you were just saying
or by the time you need the
what you're concerned about in terms of
the covet 19 or a similar type panda
endemic and some number of years out
there salesforce are probably out of
business and it's been some other system
that's come into place so i'm just
wondering
why
you think that this is a good long-term
investment i get the short-term needs
that you might use your sales for
salesforce licenses for for other
purposes
but that's not what you're asking for
here that's not the funding you're
asking for here
so
not
not having a registration system in
place
was a gap prior to covid so it was
something that public health had wanted
and had in their vision before this so
it's
you know it's valuable
outside of the context of a large-scale
pandemic
it's important it's important for us to
yes you may uh thank you madam chair
okay so during last budget cycle one of
the things that
we heard that was compelling
was
that we had a number of i.t systems that
were
no longer being supported and as a
result
of their lack of support we were
increasingly subjecting ourselves to
some security risks
so when i see that we are investing in
the sales force platform i'm just
curious are are we are we executing the
plan that we talked about a year ago
which was
getting off of vulnerable legacy systems
by migrating some
functions to
i would call salesforce a
state-of-the-art kind of
application
yes um that you hit the nail on the head
there
if we go out now on the modernization
effort if we go out to bid
for a new system for example or a
replacement of an older system
um it's highly likely that one that um
respondents will be using one of the the
two large platforms that are out there
today one of them being salesforce and
the other being microsoft dynamics 365.
in the case of
you know case management which is what
we're kind of talking about here and and
also grants management potentially
throughout the state our enterprise
solution
is salesforce
so when we look at the you know
dhhs has multiple case management
systems the vision there is is to
you know over time to collapse those
down and leverage the licenses that
we've invested in across the agency and
across the other agencies as well there
are other agencies are very interested
in and have and are actually running
are there any further questions
seeing none could i have a motion please
i'd like to move the item
uh thank you
representative edwards
moves fis 22 238
do i have a second
second by senator rosenwald
will the clerk please call the role
the roll call for 238 representative
edwards yes cameron votes yes
representative irv no
representative leishman yes
senator daniels no
senator morris yes
senator gray yes
senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair of the voters eight to two
the vote being eight to two on fis 22 to
uh the item passes
department of administrative services
and
if i am
not mistaken
we're going to talk about not only
uh fis 22 240 in tab seven
but we're also going to talk about
242 in
tab 8
239 in tab 9
and
in tab
so that because these are all
interrelated
that
we felt that it would be
the best thing to
kind of get some sort of
central thought process on what's going
on
okay um so i'm charlie arlinghouse i'm
the commissioner of administrative
there are two pairs of items right
there's a policy proposal and then the
then the money piece the actual thing
senate bill 226 uh which uh passed and
was recently signed by the governor of
those we were preparing the documents we
weren't sure
created the possibility for the state to
do uh recruitment programs retention
programs etc and
that law requires fiscal committee
approval of a requires a division of
personnel of admin services to adopt a
statewide policy on both types of things
and then for any
uh uh iteration of such a thing
done by any agency
uh for both of those things to come
before fiscal they're two separate
things so the two things that are later
in your agenda are the policies without
which these are not legal um so i'm
going to assume that if either one of
these passes you'll likely adopt a
policy that makes it legal
but the policies themselves are sort of
a broad structure
i don't think they require a lot of
explanation it's a lot of formal policy
work and uh matt maverick was sitting
behind me did a lot of the policy work
but if we have have legally questions um
i'm gonna drag him up here in particular
um so they're two different things and
i'm gonna talk about them from the the
smaller uh price tag one to the bigger
price tag one because they're very
different
so there are a lot of ways that people
retain employees or get employees today
and and you know
you see the signs of dunkin donuts you
know
signing bonus or free donuts and we
don't do free donuts as a state but we
might do other things but the one of
them the the smaller item is which i
think is fiscal uh
is a
referral incentive program
and the idea behind that is we need
employees and we're looking for them and
and one of the ways you get employees is
that people interview and they come in
the door so
this is something where we basically
turn the entire workforce into
recruiters for the state and that if you
if you get somebody to come work here
you can
you're responsible for recruiting them
and it would be done on the application
as a formal way to do it to make sure we
don't run into he said she said things
and we do actually hire the person that
there is uh there is a bonus both for
the new employee assuming you stay for a
while there's a bonus bonus both for the
new employee
and
for the referrer referrer
i think i said that right um
that's the one program and i think
that's the program that probably
everybody looks at and says okay this
isn't a bad idea because
we if we don't get anybody we don't
spend a dime
and if we uh if we end up spending money
it's because we we got employees that um
work through the system
um
the second thing and i think it's the
one that you're most interested in
discussing
is
which is a retention incentive similar
to some of the programs that were done
during the state of emergency this is
something we work directly with the
governor's office on
obviously you probably figured that out
um
that given that it's a admin services
proposal and none of the money goes to
anybody who works at admin services
which i'm not complaining about by the
way but it's for direct care um direct
care people so it's basically you know
new hampshire hospital gun cliff center
center et cetera and the prison
obviously and the idea is that the the
staffing pressures there are a lot of
staffing pressures all across state
government but the staffing pressures in
in direct care positions is quite
significant right now and um
um this is something where you can't
just not do a policy or or or your
workload reduced at the end of the day
the prison has to function period i'm
using the prison as an example but this
works for all of them and they have to
function and if 10 people leave you
don't sort of curtail your operation and
have uh
you know have 14 of the prisoners work
from home
because that sort of doesn't work in a
prison and so the idea is to try to try
to retain the staff this would end up
applying to about um
um i think we have the numbers in on
page uh i don't have page numbers here
oh page six
so i think it's um
well i used to be able to see 1300
full-time 280 part-time people
uh those positions aren't all filled
obviously nobody would get a bonus if
the position weren't filled but we're
actively recruiting lots of them
um
so um you know about 15 of the state
workforce if you want to think of it
that way but the idea is to take people
who already work here and try to keep
them from leaving because one of your
best recruiting tools um is to retain an
employee and not have to fill it over
so that's that that's the idea behind
this and it's the it's the kind of
procedure that was done during the um
during the state of emergency and i
think that um
i don't want to speak for the governor's
office but you know we worked uh hand in
glove with them to um
to develop the program and and they have
a very strong interest and and as do
uh people in these departments obviously
in trying to trying to keep employees
and
and reduce staffing shortages
i think the price tag is all laid out
some for full time some for part time if
that helps if that's a question people
might wonder about right
the idea is to make part-time positions
eligible in both of these cases for
things as well
a lot of work in state government is
representative edwards
uh thank you madam chair um
about five years ago um i went and
visited uh i think mr gilley
after
trying to
use the state's
employment website
to search for
jobs of different categories just to see
how it the look and feel works for a
typical potential employee
five years ago
we were using i think a free application
that was just horrible it wasn't worth
the money we were paying for it i'd like
to know
in the five years
has the department been able to get a
professional
job recruitment website up to where
people can effectively search for
vacancies and and qualifications and the
like like if they're a veteran
can they find out which jobs are open
you know preferences to veterans for
example do we have a good website or is
it still a five-year-old stinker i um
it's not still a five-year-old stinker
but um the the question do we have a
good website or is it a five-year-old
stinker presumes um two options and
there are lots of options in the middle
of that range
i think we have a good website what
we're using now is the is the talent
management module talent management is
what the those those kind of people all
use to
talk about hiring um the talent
management module of the infor system
which is the state's erp system that
governs our finances payroll et cetera
and the idea is to integrate the two um
we have since about um
october of 2017 made significant changes
um to that website and and
basically we had a meeting where the
the governor decided to do what you did
too and he tried to apply for a job and
i think we rejected him and he was
unqualified for
um a cleaner position he applied for
and
he had trouble applying
uh one of the things was the the
different browsers you can use to access
it and we've changed that
i would say every few months we have a
team that
regularly looks at this the
the the hrp section of
fdm which is one of our divisions that
manages the enterprise system and so we
make changes um all the time
i would say that where we are today is
that it's
better
and it's getting better and it gets
better every day but when we talk about
recruitment i um
[Music]
i ask um i told you this before that i'd
interview everybody we hire um lately
and so you know think of it as maybe
maybe over the last um nine months about
100 people
um that have sort of passed through and
one of the questions i ask almost all of
them it sort of depends how the
interview's going is how did you find
applying for a job how did you find
interacting with the state
and and i would say that um
there's still a range on that and i what
i'm pleased about is that there are a
number of people it's a particularly
important thing externally right and and
um you know in the state system
[Music]
you know maybe 30 percent of the people
come external and 70 are
are moving from one state job to another
um
but people who who are familiar with
applying for jobs in the market today
are
more optimistic about our system because
with so many larger companies in
particular
there are systems you sign up you
register
you create an account and all of that
kind of stuff and that's the that's the
pain of the process most of the jobs
i've applied for in my
entire life have been resume and cover
letter sent sent through the us postal
service to somebody and so you know i
would so i find the system horrifying
and and freakish
and um well don't
don't say that when alex is here but the
um
but if you're used to this if you're
used to applying for jobs electronically
you're much much more used to it now and
so what i would say is we're getting
better and i would hope that we're at
about a b minus at this point
and um which is unacceptable because i
think we lose applicants because of it
um
but we get better all the time
are there any further questions
uh senator daniels
thank you
if i was an employee and you were trying
to retain me you give me a two thousand
dollar
retention
uh bonus i guess uh it looks like the
requirement is that i stay for 90 to 180
days
is that correct there's a uh yeah
there's a time frame i don't i don't
know what the exact uh difference
between the two dates is but july 1st to
november 3rd
so you have you you have to be here on
july 1st and you have to stay through
november 3rd
yeah this is probably like 125 days
one of the other items i mean one of
them mentions new hires and
oh that's on the referral yes that one
sorry and then there was one for
retention which mentioned 180
90 to 180 days
i guess my question is
when when that time is over is the
expectation that this retention bonus is
going to continue
or are we just paying somebody that's a
one-time payment okay so the think of
the on on a referral uh think of it this
way
um
you know i've got an open position uh
i'm interviewing right now for a cfo if
you're interested
and um you come in you apply for the job
and it turns out that that that oh let's
just say matt matt recommended you on
your job application you say recommended
by met maverick george if we hire you
the clock starts ticking and i like
nudge matt and go hey let's see if he
stays
and then if you stay you stay through
the time you're supposed to stay then
you both get a check
you don't get another check in six
months you don't get another check six
months after that it's now and we're
going to see if that works on some basic
level this is an experiment
to see if that really does in fact make
a difference i by the way i suspect it
does or you know mcdonald's and dunkin
donuts and
and uh
you know lincoln financial and everybody
else wouldn't do it too
yes and that's not not my question my
question is specifically about the
retention
part not not not the referral uh no
retention same way we're asking you to
asking you to stay and then and it's a
one-time payment yes and
[Music]
so basically we are paying somebody two
thousand dollars to stay 90 days
the i think i i think if you think about
it sort of philosophically the idea is
to to
um
you know there's obviously obviously not
a long life to this you you can't do
that where you you every quarter for the
rest of their career you give somebody
you just give somebody two grand if they
make it another quarter in another
quarter because if nothing else that
just becomes part of base pay but it's
basically right now we're in a we're in
a time period where where there's a lot
of churn
and we have a lot of issues in hiring
people
and um and uh and that's particularly
true you know i don't speak for hhs or
corrections but it's particularly true
in some of those areas we talk a lot
about nurses but it's not just nurses
it's a you know direct people who do
direct care and work sort of
um in care or behind the wall or
whatever have you
and and that's where there's a lot of
pressure and and the idea is to um in in
a in an uh
a time period of high vacancies is try
to keep that from exploding
and to try to keep a lid on it
there are a lot of things that aren't
ideal right now and this is one of them
okay and i understand that i guess i
just
question because it doesn't seem so
90 to 100 or you say 125 days is an
extraordinary amount of time
for the for the money that you that
you're putting out i mean it basically
equates to like six thousand dollars a
year if it were continuous but
for some for someone that was looking to
leave
you know to stay for 90 days i'm not
sure really what it's giving us
um it's a no so it's a good question one
of the things when you're constructing a
program like this and and you think of
the
you know i said we worked with the
governor's office on this and frankly
you know where the governor's office
started is is we want to do something we
want to we want to and in in this realm
and they look for recommendations on
time periods it's an argument to be made
for 30 days that i think it's too i
think it's too short but there's an
argument to be made for a year
i'm not going to give you any money
unless you unless you unless you stay
for another year
and um and probably
you know every number in between i think
the the the finalists for the time
period that we considered are probably
three months and and six months
and um
[Music]
it's it's it's one of those things you
know
if i'm honest we're you know there's no
science around us and so we're we're
making a judgment call
thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none
uh could i please have a quick question
about you i'm sorry that's quite all
right
go ahead thanks madam cheer
um thanks charlie for appearing in your
um
comic relief at times that's appreciated
so as i understand
you're all in all four items i believe
you said that we have a vacancy rate
that is approaching 20
uh people are leaving at a roughly 12
percent um
what are we doing for incentives to
keeping people here i understand that
arpa funds are going to be used for
people that take care of prisoners and
the department of health and human
services areas but what about dot and
des are there any funds available
for retention of those departments for
instance or even your department
no so it said it's one of those things
there's a there's a sort of an obvious
comment to make when you're retaining
direct care people um which is you know
something along the lines of so
accountants don't matter
and uh um i say that because i have a
lot of accountants um but um and it's
not true and the thing is that you know
you can make a case for doing this with
basically every profession in the state
every worker group in the state and um
you know i would love to do it for
building service workers um i've talked
to you in the past about about that
issue we're doing a lot of things to try
to recruit and retain people and there's
a you know we we've uh gave the lb a
chart and if we i know we're you're
going to want to talk later about
vacancy rates and all of that and and
what the recruitment unit is doing and
we can talk about that
but um one of the things is that in a
in a climate where we are where we are
today there are there are some things
you can do and some things you can't do
i think that bonuses of this nature are
meant to be by their
uh
nature i guess
extraordinary
right and not not structured in such a
way that they would become commonplace
um
so what you're what you're left to doing
if you want to retain good people that
you have is you try your damnedest to do
it and if you are you know there's an
incentive part of the incentive is i
think every manager wants to be a good
manager in part because they i would
hope are
nice people
but part of it is um
it's really difficult when somebody
valuable to you leaves and frankly when
you have 80 percent of your position
filled everybody's pretty valuable
um when somebody leaves there's an
enormous
time crunch and difficulty with them
leaving and so a lot of what you do is
you you try to make sure you run around
and you're nice to people
you try to emphasize the things the
state does well you know the state you
know state wage scale is a little bit
lower um say benefits are really good
and the time off is really good and you
make sure you work with people and you
that they can utilize the time off and
you know which is a which can be a
burden if somebody took all the
you know 10 or 15-year employee took
every every annual day every floating
holiday and used up all their sick leave
you know that's it's um it's like 20 to
25 percent of the year they could they
could miss
and uh and you have to work with that
and so and so that's a lot of it you
know the frankly the things that that
anybody can do at any company or any any
unit
to try to keep employees
um
are
human more than financial i mean don't
get me wrong
you know financial hi um you're offering
me 70 the other job's offering me 95.
guess which one i'm taking
that's an issue but if you can get into
the conversation then a lot of it is is
they need to
they need to think that they're that's a
good place to work and it needs to be a
good place to work
thank you
thank you madam chair
are there any further questions
seeing none um
i would like a motion on
fis
22 240.
this is on the
4 million
or
um employee bonus
thank you senator d'alessandro second by
senator rosenwald
okay will the clerk please call the roll
we'll call on 240.
representative edwards yes
hamrick votes yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator remorse
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes
madam chair of the vote is 10-0
uh the vote on fis 22-240
is 10-0 it passes
take 242
and
so
remove the items okay thank you
all right thank you
representative leitchman and uh senator
d'alessandro
since these are all
tied together
i'd appreciate it so thank you
representative how will you call the
rule please
so let's roll call for 2 30 2 42 239 and
representative edwards
yes
emeric votes yes representative erf yes
representative leishman yes
representative daniels senator daniel
sorry yes senator morse yes senator gray
yes senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes representative berger
yes madam chairman yes vote is 10-0 on
all three okay the vote being 10 to zero
fi is 22 239
and two third whoops
and
242 all passed so thank you
we'll now turn to tab
fis 22 233
request from the
oops i don't think you're on thank you
good morning diane martin director of
the administrative office of the courts
here with donna raymond our fiscal
manager
thank you are there any questions for
the judicial branch
thank you senator d'alessandro moves
do i have a second
second by senator rosenwald
will the clerk please call the role
we'll call on 233 representative edwards
yes enrique yes representative earth yes
representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator morris yes senator
gray yes senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes representative umberger
yes madam chair of the voters 10-0
thank you very much thank you very much
you got away easy today
don't expect that every time okay all
right
no thank you very much
okay we now move to tab 11
from the department of corrections
that's
good morning madam chair and honorable
members of the committee for the record
helen hanks commissioner of the
department of corrections and to my
right as our director of administrative
services jonathan hanson
thank you
are there
are there any questions uh senator
rosenwald thank you madam chair not a
question but
i didn't want to take your earlier item
off consent but i'd like to congratulate
the department on its fantastic use of
the 340b
program to save
really a million dollars in six months
on two kinds of drugs
is fantastic
and i hope the
county houses of correction
are
looking at that fantastic program too
and
maybe someday they can coordinate with
you to
purchase those drugs for hep c and
hiv
and also save that kind of money it's
fantastic
thank you senator rosenwald and i would
be remiss if i didn't thank commissioner
shibanet and her team at hhs to helping
us get to this final place and um with
that i also reaffirmed we were just
recertified so we'll continue down that
road and if there's an opportunity to
collaborate then we'll certainly do that
yippee
representative leashman
uh thanks madam chair and i guess i'd
just like to echo what senator rosenwald
said in
uh the
uh
chairman chairwoman
mentioned earlier the detailed and
responses we've been getting have been
much better and i just want to
tackle that as well your uh recruiting
and retention efforts and the attachment
was very good so thank you
thank you sir
senator d'alessandro thank you very much
madam chair i think the the information
that you've presented to us is really
outstanding and i can recall when we had
these discussions about pharmaceuticals
a number of years ago
and it's nice to see something very
positive happen as a result of those
discussions
in in
the course of our discussions they said
we could save money there was a
methodology in place to do it and we
could do it hopefully
that same situation will occur in the
recruitment and retention part so that
we'll retain corrections offices and be
able to recruit so that our overtime
will be
be lower and uh we'll be able to fill
those spots so kudos to the department
and thank you so much for uh paying
attention to detail thank you thank you
sir
okay
okay is that all right
go ahead
uh thank you i i was reading um i think
it was the union leader this past week
or so and uh the main subject was
the sununu youth center
but in it there was also an allegation
that we are picking up on sexual and
physical abuse and i think the
corrections department
and so i wanted to
ask you
um what what we're doing
proactively
to to try to
do what we can to make sure that
if there is abuse that it stopped
and i and whether or not you think we do
have a situation where we've got some
problems
thank you for that question
representative edwards and i'm very
proud of our organization we have been
certified under the prison rape
elimination act for a number of years
and actually we just finished a cycle
audit at our women's facility in shea
farm and we've passed those audits year
after year that information is available
on our internet page
we do an excellent job surveilling
educating
and moving forward that your sentence
does not equal sexual assault and
creating pathways for that communication
and we have dedicated what are called
pria investigators that investigate
allegations of both residential resident
resident to staff
and numerous variables under the federal
pria law in addition to that and
thankfully so governor council also just
passed a contract will allow us to
further create both educational videos
of residents who've been incarcerated
and staff staff education materials
that will continue to elevate both our
surveillance education in response to
allegations of sexual assault during
incarceration
yeah so thank you for for everything
you're doing in that area i i think the
allegation was
made in a self-serving way
but i just wanted to get you
on the record this way to say what we're
doing and whether or not you regard us
having a problem in this area
thank you for your answer you're very
welcome uh i have a motion from senator
daniels
seconded by representative edwards
will the clerk please call the roll roll
call on 228 representative edwards yes
pearmic votes yes represent irf yes
representative leishman yes senator
daniels yes senator morse yes senator
gray yes senator rosenwald yes senator
d'alessandro yes
representative umberger yes madam chair
the vote is ten to zero vote being ten
passes
we now turn to the late item
fis-22243
and that is
located
in tab
eleven
twelve i've got a twelve okay
mine's in eleven okay i whatever
it's someplace back there
and
this is a request from the governor's
hello again
taylor caswell um
this is uh an item that came to us
in between
the deadlines this is funding that is
the second
half of funding that already has gone to
virtually every community in the state
as part of their fiscal recovery funds
local fiscal recovery funds
the state received a second tranche of
this funding a couple of well just about
a week ago
and we really didn't want a delay in
moving those funds forward
all of the communities
that received this fund have already
indicated their willingness and they've
were had all the appropriate paperwork
taken care of to move that it's just a
simple matter of
getting those funds transferred to those
communities as soon as we can
so the total amount of the requests here
is 56 million dollars give or take a
little bit um it mirrors the exact
amount that we distributed just about a
year ago for the same purpose
are there any questions
seeing none will the clerk call the role
oh i'm sorry thank you senator roosevelt
and senator daniels
i'm just getting a little anxious here
i'm sorry
okay will the clerk please call the roll
roll call on two zero two two
representative edwards yes
oh i'm sorry
my mistake 243. thank you representative
edwards
yes on that one too okay
emmerich votes yes represent irv yes
representative leishman yes
senator daniels yes senator morse yes
senator gray yes senator rosenwald yes
senator d'alessandro yes representative
umberger yes and i'm sure the vote is 10
to nothing
the vote being 10 to nothing
22-243 passes
okay
we have um
several information
items
i understand that
health and human services withdrew
information item 2227
otherwise
are there any questions on any of these
information no items
okay seeing none
we'll move to the audit information
items
uh
representative leishman i understood you
her corrections
is that correct of liquor
go ahead and introduce myself good
morning rose wyatt director of
administration and chief operating
officer
we do have more of a crew out in the
hallway they're making their way in okay
i know these meetings get to be a little
boring but uh for you that for those
that uh aren't in the uh in the hot seat
so
not a problem welcome back everyone
thank you i'll just start and see if i
can answer questions and okay
go ahead
representative leitchman yes uh thank
you and thanks for being here
so on a number of items it talks about a
management plan being completed but then
it goes on to say
written plan nearing completion i was
just kind of curious what that all meant
of course
just to
to keep for continuity throughout this
process as we've been updating this
corrective action plan
we haven't deleted anything so that's
just showing the progress along the way
the part in bold is the current
information
it's just that was just
along the way as it was being developed
that those comments are still there in
the notes
and then just one further quick question
uh there was a section i don't seem to
have it right in front of me but you're
going to rules for some changes and it
says uh you're either going or there
where's what's the status of your
rules presentation
we have several rules in development or
currently in the jail car process
um the licensing rules
which i know show up in here there are
several rules that show up in here
several places
the licensing rules have all been
updated and completed those are in place
that's chapter 700
we're currently in the
over at jail car
for a section of rules chapter 500
oh those relate to particular licenses
currently in the drafting process are
the rules pertaining to
the enforcement policy
which would be like sanctions and fines
and so forth as well as the um
the hearings and procedural process
and just one quick further follow-up
chair thank you
so during the review of legislation last
year we learned that reports that
everyone thought were going to
fiscal or finance were going to mr hunt
over in commerce is that all
straightened out now are those
being forwarded to the chair of the
good morning deputy chief danielle
elston with new hampshire liquor
enforcement um we are still sending them
to commerce we can send them direct to
the chair of fiscal if we need to we
continue to send them to commerce uh the
the direction for
the report came out of commerce um but
if we can continue we can send them to
the chair fiscal if that's what
what we choose yeah i think that was the
agreement i was at the commerce
committee when it came up and i think mr
hunt said he thought they would should
go to finance or the fiscal chair
but okay thank you we can send them
thanks thanks manager that's all i have
are there any further questions on this
audit
seeing none
um
are there any questions on
the
audit on uh sununu youth center
since hhs left i hope not
okay
um next meeting
our next meeting is scheduled for
i i i was just curious um
we we just had somebody come up to talk
about an informational item are you
gonna have mr ribson talk about
his quarterly report or or not i can get
with him offline no i just asked if
anyone had any questions
on
fis-22218
and nobody said they did i'm sorry okay
yes i did have all right
then thank you mr ribson
yeah boy you
don't you almost escaped i'm i'm i'm
sorry the the number didn't uh shake me
but
um i
uh okay so so mr ribson i i'm looking at
uh unresolved item number one and when i
go read what it says it says
this is the legislature's issue to solve
i'm just curious since it sounds like
there are several statutes involved
are you working with the legislator for
legislation for the coming term next
term
and if so who
at this point um i'm unaware of any
legislative interest in addressing item
number one i i think we're obligated to
be interested right i mean you know you
i okay so so we'll talk about that uh
offline but
um but i i i've been getting involved in
the sununu center a lot in the last
couple years so i i could help you with
that i think
then on uh item six
uh observation six it says
to go ahead and institute comprehensive
performance measures after the strategic
plan is done it looks like your
strategic plan is now done
do you have any roadblocks to keep you
from fully resolving observation six
yeah what we've what we've said in both
both the strategic plan
these things were all done anticipating
um that we would be moving forward the
legislation that was being considered
this this past session in terms of
moving into the new facility
um
changing the the clinical program
everything aligned with that so
we're in a little bit of a limbo right
now as to how to actually operationalize
and whether to operationalize those
things because we're not quite sure
what the future holds
we're currently in a moment where
state law would have the facility close
in march of 2023 with absolutely no
alternative in place
all right so i'm just playing check
marks with you now you've got a check
mark and substantially resolved as i
listen to what you're saying sounds to
me like you're partially resolved at the
best
yeah well we have we had the plan laid
out in place was all incorporated within
the a m plan and incorporated in our
strategic priorities but to move forward
we need to kind of understand what's
what the future holds all right uh thank
you for your indulgence madam chair oh
no no problem
thank you
okay
uh i'll now
try again
oh yes
just a a quickie
in the report that we got from hhs
um
just the the
the numbers are so tiny that i can't
read them and i've talked about that
over and over and over again
they've got to do something if they're
going to give us information
make the information readable
so that we can get something out of it i
realize it's not your
responsibility but i've been looking at
these things for a number of years
and they've gotten smaller
as the years have gone by
my eyesight has not improved
substantially so
we've got to make a change there yes
we've got to have that i believe
that senator rosenwald has agreed
to
she and i
working on an overhaul
of this report oh great over the summer
sherlock
yeah we need more well we will not have
any
yeah we will not have any sherlock
holmes magnifying glasses
but that's necessary but um
we all recognize that
we want the report to be useful yes and
meet the needs of the
the fiscal committee and so
we'll come up with something right and
my second point is
with the recruitment and retention we
were going to get a report
either periodically or
meeting every other meeting but as to
what's happened how successful it's been
what's happened to the number of
vacancies how many have been filled
and uh how that how that's going just to
keep us all abreast of how things are
moving and i'm particularly interested
in that i sponsored the bill
uh happy that it obviously passed but
but indeed we should be kept up to date
as to what's going on
so mr arlingham you you'll provide that
for july
we do uh just to cut into madame chair
we did send an email from charlie with
kind of an update i think some of the
okay
oh okay go ahead
i'm sorry i'm i must have missed the
email
oh
oh you mean you mean while i was driving
down
you wanted me to uh
good
great great
perfect
person
i think we should talk about it since um
okay with me our uh kate mullavy is head
of the recruitment unit our new
recruitment unit and matt mavrogeorge is
a director of personnel
i'm sorry
the deputy director personnel boy lori
would just kill me right and i won't
tell you which is which but you might be
um
so a couple things there's so there's a
document in front of you that that kate
prepared which is the numbers the only
change from the thing that we sent
before is that the vacancy rate is 20.6
and um
i don't want to say that doesn't matter
but there's a chart in the back i think
it's page four that kind of shows what's
happening but what's going on is not
that we're anticipating making immediate
changes that will affect a rate
we're doing a lot of things i remember
you know back in the day people would
ask about you know we're talking about
economic development or budgeting or
something like that and someone said
what's the one thing we need to do
and i said the one thing we need to do
is to stop thinking there's one thing
that we need to do
because there's no one thing that's
going to make a difference on anything
and this is true of any major project
you have but on recruiting in the state
we're not there's not one thing that
we're not doing if um if something
happened and you saw immediate movement
it would be because oh it turned out we
forgot to flip a switch and now we're
getting eight times as many applicants
no there are a lot of little things
um kate and her team of
three people and and matt is a integral
part of this um are working on doing a
lot of things and if you look at the
bullet points on major milestones a lot
of them you're going to look at and say
well that doesn't sound like that big a
thing but everything is a big thing
everything's a little thing and all the
little things start adding up
you know and i'm going to give one
example that i'm directly familiar with
from from a few years ago
we
um
we have a lot of building service
workers which is a part-time position
doing cleaning
we have a lot of them based in the city
of concord
who are not native english speakers a
lot of them are
from from immigrant communities or new
americans or
um
or refugees or what have you and
it turned out that you know the typical
way of recruiting for a position like
that
um doesn't really work
but we had we have a number of people
inside those communities who we did
flyers and at some point somebody did a
flyer and had one of them
translated into
nepali i'm going to say but i might be
wrong about that
and
and passed it out it helped we got four
or five applicants that we didn't have
and it's the whole thing about word of
mouth one little thing that made a
little tiny difference it doesn't affect
any data point or our numbers but for
the
for the buildings that started getting
clean that weren't well they were
getting cleaned but the pressure on the
on the building crew that made a
difference so everything we're doing is
designed to make a little bit of
difference
and i think we're i think we're getting
there there is a data point in here that
shows you
what happens i talked to you before
about how this how there's a churn so i
think it's page two net hires by pay
period we hire people we terminate
people
termination just means they left it
doesn't mean they got fired right you
retire your your position is terminated
and all of that and you you see the net
number is negative a lot of times we've
had positive we've had negative we
actually had a really good
pay period we hire on fridays i think
people know that everybody starts work
on a friday
before i came to fiscal i actually wrote
an email to my department about the
five new people who were starting this
particular friday and saying make sure
you wave and say hi to them as you walk
by
and um so everybody starts on friday and
this is what happened on the last
30-ish fridays
and um
so we're going to be analyzing that data
and kind of figuring out how that works
at the end of the day one of the things
we can do
recruitment is going to be a little bit
like curling
for us as a state
and
there are national trajectories that are
ongoing and we're gonna we can sweep to
i don't you know watch curling at the
olympics right you sweep and you kind of
move it a little bit this way or a
little bit this way so we're trying to
move it a little bit this way nobody's
gonna flip a switch and we're go we're
gonna go from 20 and next month i'm
going to come to you and go hey it was
20.4 last month now it's 8.5 wow we
hired like a thousand and six people
that's just never going to happen so
what we're hoping to do is to reverse
that trend
that trend is only reversed by a lot of
hard work by hiring managers
and it's not it's to some extent um hard
work by the people to my right but
to some extent to a large extent it's
them helping other people get the work
done we're going to certify positions
faster you apply for the state job you
get certified you get an answer faster
you get
um
disposition faster so you know you got
the job you know you didn't get the job
we encourage those people to apply for
other jobs in the state system and you
can see here that some of the some of
the research work done you know we found
people who were interested in a state
job and didn't get one and then just
sort of languishing out in the ethernet
somewhere and and moving that forward
and so that that's the big picture on
kind of where we're going and and i
think it's going to get worse before it
gets better
but
we're finding a lot of a lot of things
to work on that are that are making
those small differences that we need to
make
thank you are there any further
questions
yes uh
represent emery
with the
pressures of inflation and
etc etc etc
do you think we're going to see some
retirees coming off the bench
to come back into at least part-time
employment
well the short answer is i hope so i
mean we have
um
we have a number of people this this
happens a lot lately i mean it happened
in state service for a while but um
you know i i have a i have a guy who is
um you know he's passed social security
full-time age and um well so i i think a
lot of people here know you know mike
connor who retired as deputy
commissioner in 2017 and did everything
and anything to do with property and
public works and procurement and and was
an institution in the state so he
retired we got him to come back part
time and i'm making sure to drop by and
explain to him that you know if you wait
till you're 70 to take social security
it goes up eight percent a year those
three years just so you know
and to kind of put that off um we try to
do a lot of that we have uh you know i
see a guy in the in the basement all the
time who um used to work for weights and
measures
in in the department of agriculture and
he's and there aren't that's a thing
where
you know i didn't i hadn't even heard
the term metrologist
before uh before i started looking at
the state budget and they have a new
metrologist and this guy is on board
because there aren't a lot of them and
he's uh he's 25 30 hours a week and
we talk and when i see him in the
basement about retiree health a lot
and so um
we're doing everything we can with that
i think it i think it's an effective
solution
in some
managerial positions it requires you
just to rethink how you do things
where
there's an old-fashioned attitude that
you know everybody i have i need to have
full time
and um you get used to like well what i
really need is another is another you
know
another fred
and uh maybe what you need are two half
fred's
and and and by the way just for the
record two half reds are actually
cheaper
and so and if it happens to be a fred
who actually knows what they're doing
you know i have a some of you may have
met um joe bouchard before and i had a
conversation with him on his last day
which didn't go anywhere but i said just
so you know
once the summer's over and you're tired
of the black flies biting you up in
maine
i'm sure we could work something out
because you'd because i'd grab a guy
who already knew what the heck he was
doing
instead of bringing somebody in and
having to train them and go okay so the
budget this is going to sound weird to
you but
and because he already knows all the
weird stuff and so it's easier so
are there any further questions
yeah thank you very much for this report
oh
representative
thank you madam chair could you just
remind me what a
non-classified position is and how many
there are
um
yes sort of
so the entire state workforce almost
without exception is divided into
classified and unclassified unclassified
are largely the gnc appointments but a
couple other categories
the governor's staff is non-classified
their salary they're not budgeted at
anything he could theoretically pay one
guy 500 grand
and somebody else six
it's an argument i made when i worked
there didn't go anywhere but
legislative employees are also
non-classified it means they're not part
of any system and they're not part of a
scale they tend to be
weird one-offs here and there
and in the executive branch there's
almost none of it except political
appointees historically it was meant to
be used for people who are
political appointees and and serve at
the at the whim of somebody else and fit
certain categories under federal fll
senator rosenwald thank you
at one point we
um approved money here
for some employees at hampstead hospital
they were going to be non-classified too
which was i think the first time i ever
heard that was that the only place aside
from the governor's office
and the legislature that we were going
to have non-classified
i think that's true but i think there
are a couple of onesies and twosies do
oh first-year attorneys at department of
justice before they're commissioned are
technically non-classified in a
different way
but by the way the hampstead hospital
people i'm pretty sure my understanding
of this is right and sherry can raise
their hand on the back if i'm wrong is
that that's temporarily non-classified
while they're in the process of going
through jcec approval
to create the to do the evaluation for
where they should be in the unclassified
system
i think
but we're getting rid of them anyway
we're what we're
we're eliminating those
when they turn into because we did
something
statutory when yeah when they switch the
old thing goes away the thing that's a
okay are there any further questions
all right now can i and finally announce
the uh next meeting
okay
oh yeah well it's on it's uh
yeah it's all there um
our next meeting will be on july
22nd
at 10 a.m
and then we will
skip august
and hopefully we won't have any
emergencies so that we have to come in
but
thank you all
for coming today and for those of you
watching i hope you have enjoyed it
and i will now ask for a motion to
adjourn
representative leishman seconded by
representative emrick all those in favor
opposed
you